Last question today is from Jeremy.
Jeremy says, Hey David, are you worried that
the Sanders Warren, uh, candidacy are going
to candidacies?
I guess I'm trying to sort of reread this
in a way that makes sense.
Let me, let me reinterpret it.
David, are you worried that both Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren running, we'll split
the progressive vote if neither of them drop
out, allowing the other to coalesce the progressive
vote Sanders we'll have an early lead in delegates
if he does well in earlier states.
I think that right now there is no reason
whatsoever to believe that both Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren running is going to hurt
the progressive movement.
In fact, I think right now there's a benefit
to both Bernie and Elizabeth Warren running,
which is that even though they are both considered
to be sort of the left, most candidates that
are running, they actually have different
approaches and different styles and different
policy ideas.
Bernie Sanders comes more from the democratic
socialist, uh, of an enclave of the left and
he has moved to running a campaign of social
democracy.
Elizabeth Warren comes more from the let's
tweak capitalism to better work for the middle
class enclave of the Democratic Party and
has moved to the left to a position of social
democracy that is also very close to Bernie
Sanders, but their approaches in terms of
policy are quite different when you look at
everything ranging from healthcare to education
policy to other things.
Is one better than the other?
Well, I think Bernie is slightly too.
Elizabeth Warren's left and I am more left,
so on policy, I'm probably slightly more in
line with Bernie than with Elizabeth Warren,
but Elizabeth Warren is running an awesome
substantive campaign.
She's going to red states and doing town halls
and talking to Trump voters and other conservatives
head on in a way that is a really great thing
to be doing and he's engaging directly with
people who might never imagine that they would
vote even though I think she's from Oklahoma,
for a senator from Massachusetts in terms
of the sort of political space that Elizabeth
Warren occupies now.
So right now Bernie and Warren running is
a really, really great thing.
Eventually it's going to be sorted out.
They can't both be the nominees and I believe
that they are both aware of the impacts of
each of their campaigns on the other.
I believe that as the debates get going, as
the polling numbers start to firm up in terms
of how they will look as the primary start,
either or both of them are going to do the
right things and in the long run I think that
they are going to grow the total base of progressive
support rather than divide it.
And I think it's an absolutely great thing.
They both are people who understand pragmatic
realities.
They are both people who, uh, want the movement
to succeed first and foremost.
And I think they're going to do the right
thing.
I am not worried about that whatsoever.
And the way I see it, you know, sometimes
people say, David, you know, when you see
other progressive hosts growing their audience,
do you feel as though they're your competition
and they're hurting you in some way?
The answer is no.
I mean, on a practical level, people only
have a certain number of hours of the day
during which they consume media.
So in some very strict sense, if someone starts
watching a half hour a day of something else,
that's a half hour a day of me that they may
not be watching.
But I have a different approach, which is
that progressive independent media is such
a small thing relative to the larger universe
of stuff people can watch or listen to that
I see other progressive shows as growing the
pie rather than taking a bigger slice of it.
And I think that there's a very similar analogy
to what's going on now with the progressive
movement within the Democratic Party and even
outside of it in the United States.
If you disagree with me, If you think Warren
and Bernie running at the same time is damaging
the progressive movement, I want to hear from
you.
I will listen to any and all reasonable disagreements
with my position.
Uh, that's it for today.
We've got a great bonus show coming up.
The show doesn't have to end.
Now if you become a member or a patron, you
will get instant access to the bonus show.